charles aznavour vous voici revenu en
même temps qu'elle alhambra au tour de
chant le festival de venise a révélé au
public ce qu'il ignorait encore c'est à
dire que vous êtes un grand comédien est
ce que ces succès répétés ont transformé
votre vie personnelle absolument pas ma
vie personnelle reste exactement la même
c'est à dire que ma vie personnelle
d'une vie très familial j'ai par exemple
mes parents qui habitent à mougins et ma
fille qui est là bas et qui va en
pension à ken reste avec mon père les
samedis et dimanches
on n'a publié que votre fille voulait
devenir chanteuse comme vous et que vous
en aviez autorisée est ce vrai c'est
alors qu'elle m'a dit un jour je crois
que je vais être chanteuse elle pense
que ça se fait comme ça et je lui ai
répondu ma foi si tu dois être chanteuse
tu seras chanteuse en ce qui vous
concerne vous êtes donc à la fois
comédien compositeur et chanteur
vous avez commencé par fois par le tour
de chant dont j'ai commencé par jouer la
comédie mais alors vraiment j'étais très
enfant j'avais 9 ans et puis à l'âge où
la voix mue qui savait parce que moi
aussi j'ai eu une bouée camus et là je
vous l'avoué mu à l'âge où on n'a pas le
visage très net et bien je suis venu à
la chanson et puis comme la chanson ne
nourrissait pas tellement son âme j'ai
écrit des chansons et puis ces chansons
que j'ai écrites nous ont fait un tel
succès que on m'a réclamé pour les
chanter et puis quand on m'a vu chanter
on m'a dit est ce que vous voulez jouer
la comédie je pense que c'est un cercle
qui s'est fait absolument normalement
d'où vous sortez d'ailleurs très très
bien il repose une petite question
indiscrète
à vos débuts dans la chanson votre vin a
été très discutée est ce que je peux
vous demander si vous voulez mais en
tout cas le met très utile
il faut dire que au début on m'a dit
avec cette voix là tu ne pourras jamais
réussir et puis par la suite on m'a dit
si tu n'avais pas eu cette voie là tu
n'aurais jamais réussi
alors je me pose la question maintenant
qu'est ce qui me fait réussir et autres
questions que vous pourriez peut-être
vous poser si vous étiez obligés de
choisir entre le compositeur le comédien
et le chanteur que choisiriez vous là
c'est très difficile parce que si vous
me demandez si je choisirais entre le
compositeur par exemple et le
et le comédien je vous répondrai tout de
suite je choisirais le compositeur parce
que j'aime beaucoup ce métier de
comédien seulement il me nourrit pas
spirituellement toute la journée tandis
que le compositeur est allié au chanteur
alors je chanterai le soir et j'écrirai
toute la journée
mais entre le chanteur et le comédien
entre le chanteur au dos non mais pour
moi le chanteur et compositeur c'est le
même personnage bon écoutez je ne veux
pas trop en parler je crois que vous
étiez en train de répéter lorsque nous
sommes arrivés
oui oui je suis en train de répéter je
devrais en principe répéter avec la
grande formation de paul mauriat donc
j'avais depuis trois mois et demi j'ai
pas fait cours de chant il faut d'abord
que je reprenne les paroles en bouche
alors je me mets au piano et avec mes
musiciens habituels je répète mes
chances
discutez drôle à regarder
hélas pourtant tu fais la tête mais moi
j'ai envie de rigoler c'est l'alcool qui
monte en ma tête tout l'alcool que j'ai
pris soin afin d'y puiser le courage
d'avouer
marre de toi et de tes commérages de ton
corps qui me
ça
kim hong lei
d'espoir
j'en ai assez faut bien que je te dise
tu m'exaspère d'une tyrannie
je suis bi ton sale caractère sans oser
dire que tu exagères oui tu exagères duc
c'est maintenant parfois voudrait
t'étrangler dieu que tu as changé aussi
salut
les jeunes bruaysiens d'iran
il n'a pas de coeur et la dame pourtant
temps je pense bien souvent que malgré
tout tu es ma femme
si tu voulais faire un effort tout pour
y reprendre sa glace pour maigrir un peu
de sport arrange toi devant la glace
accroche un sourire à tafas maquis bon
coeur et trompe pas
au lieu de penser que je te déteste me
méfie de la baisse
mais je me demanderais gentille re
devient la petite fille qui m'a donné
tant de
mais parfois comme par le passé
j'aimerais que tout le monde
heureusement que
tu te mets salés
tu te
c'est là